so let me ask you a little bit of
challenging question here all right have
you become a recluse because all this
stuff you're talking about is
serendipity and running into stuff and
being at a dinner and being open to
stuff now you're talking about
hey I'm not gonna play defense anymore
gonna be offense is this shift do you
worry with this shift where you have a
lot of intentionality it sounds good
but maybe you don't get the next
Instagram because you're not open to
maybe being out there a little bit
ya worry about that a few things one is
so become a recluse I mean just let's be
clear I moved to Truckee at the 7 yeah i
mean i i'd left Silicon Valley before
you know the end of 2007 I consciously
decided to go live away from everybody
else and then really invest in the
friendships and relationships I wanted
to have so basically pick people and
sake why don't you come up and hang out
well play in the snow we'll go hang out
in the lake but let's go deep right and
we do the same hot tub yeah exactly the
legendary hot tub we do the same at our
place down at the beach we do our same
at our place up in Montana it's I pick
and choose those relationships that I
really want to deeply invest in and so
it was less about you know the
serendipity of like hey I'm at a you
know at a conference and happen to bump
into somebody and they blew my mind and
it was more about what was it about some
of these relationships that expose me to
other people and so ah yeah there's
something like I think I think it's the
investing in a relationship with you
where I think I opened myself up to like
okay I think with this open angel forum
back then you were doing something
pretty interesting you were cutting
through a lot of the [ __ ] that was
starting to creep up in this industry
there you know I think you're a
counterbalance to the over
institutionalization of capital at the
time right it's like all right I'll
invest in building up friendship with
him and I just think like as a
consequence of that without even
realizing like right there was Systrom
yet you know but if I've gone to a
thousand tech conferences I was gonna
meet that guy right it's an interesting
philosophy
in a way just to be clear we knew each
other already we'd work yeah no sorry
even sistrum and I did - yeah we'd work
together at Google I just hadn't I
hadn't how to catch up and it was that
bump in yeah